♪ ♪
PETER HAMMERSTEDT:
We have to do this
under the cover of darkness.
There could be eyes watching us.
It's only through
a stealth mission, really,
that we'll have any success
intercepting
an illegal operator.
MARIANA VAN ZELLER:
I'm on the trail
of what some consider
the perfect crime.
A black market worth
more than $20 billion,
with little risk
of getting caught.
I'm told it's
like robbing a bank
in the middle of the ocean.
So you see these lights
out there on the ocean,
those are the six
super trawlers.
PETER: One of the reasons
that we're all black
is so that these super trawlers
don't see that a patrol
is under way,
that they don't see us
leaving the harbor.
MARIANA: Somewhere out there
in the darkness
are the most prolific
wildlife poachers on the planet.
Who are they?
How do they work?
And why is it so hard
to stop them?
I thought I knew black markets,
but I've never seen
anything like this.
♪ ♪
PETER: In this mass
expanse of water,
we're looking for ships
that are doing everything
that they can to hide.
♪ ♪
MARIANA: I've come to Liberia
to understand how
illegal fishing works.
PETER: These trawlers
come in direct conflict
with the local fishermen,
because they're
literally stealing fish
from the local communities here.
MARIANA: Some countries
have the resources
to protect their own waters
from poachers;
others don't.
That's why Liberia
has enlisted the help
of an international organization
called Sea Shepherd.
On board are a 30-person crew,
the Liberian Coast Guard
and my guide
to this joint patrol,
20-year Sea Shepherd veteran
Peter Hammerstedt.
Peter currently heads
Sea Shepherd's task force
in Africa,
a region plagued by overfishing.
What's causing the overfishing?
PETER: You have a European fleet
that's at a massive
overcapacity,
two and a half times
what it could sustainably fish
in European waters.
You have a Chinese
distant water fishing fleet
that has essentially wiped out
fisheries off the coast of China
and that is now seeking
waters to fish elsewhere.
And these two
massive fishing fleets
from Europe, from China,
have congregated in areas
where, historically,
there still has been fish.
Places like West Africa.
MARIANA:
There's no global framework
that governs what is legal
in the fishing industry.
That's a huge part
of the problem.
And in places like West Africa,
foreign trawlers can take
advantage of patchy regulation,
poor enforcement
and the rampant corruption
of some local officials.
It's a low-risk,
high-reward crime,
but the Sea Shepherd
is trying to change that.
PETER: Six miles offshore,
no industrial vessels
are allowed inside
of an inshore exclusion zone.
But when there's no
patrolling presence at sea,
these trawlers routinely turn
off their location transponders,
and they go in.
MARIANA: Every large commercial
fishing vessel is equipped
with an Automatic
Identification System, or AIS,
which transmits
its position at sea.
If I were to be
fishing illegal
inside the exclusion zones,
as a captain of a ship,
I would turn off the AIS?
PETER: You'd get close
to the prohibited area.
That's when you would
turn your AIS off.
And you wouldn't
reappear on AIS
until you've left
that prohibited area.
MARIANA: In order
to directly observe
suspicious fishing vessels,
we need to get closer to them
and avoid being detected.
That means we wait for the cover
of nightfall again.
♪ ♪
WOMAN: So these are the vessels
that we are looking at.
At the moment they are about
three miles away from us.
MARIANA: We're super close
to this trawler, right?
WOMAN: At the moment, yes.
We can see them.
MARIANA: Oh, you can
actually see them?
PETER: Yeah.
MARIANA: Oh, it's that,
what, light over there.
WOMAN: Yes.
MARIANA: So that's the boat
we're going after?
WOMAN: Yes.
MARIANA: The Sea Shepherd crew
has found and identified
a trawler with a known history
of turning off its AIS.
What have you guys been able
to find out about this boat?
PETER: There's not that much
known about this vessel,
which is suspicious
in and of itself.
We know that this vessel has
a long history of dark periods,
where they turn off
their location transponder.
And we know that they've done
some suspicious identity changes
in, especially, claiming
to be a Somali vessel,
as soon as
a month and a half ago.
Uh, this is a vessel
that we think is most likely
flagged to Senegal,
but with a beneficial owner
that's in Spain.
MARIANA: Peter has a long
history with the Spanish.
Back in the early 2000s,
one out of every three fish
in the Antarctic
was being caught illegally...
most by Spanish-owned vessels.
Some were brought to justice,
but six trawlers kept at it,
evading authorities
by changing their colors,
their flags
and even their names.
They were known
as the Bandit 6.
The most notorious, a vessel
that made millions
poaching Chilean sea bass,
was known as the Thunder.
And Peter helped bring it down.
PETER: We found the Thunder
fishing in a CCAMLR region.
They're not licensed
to fish down here.
There's an Interpol Purple
Notice issued for this vessel.
We've told the vessel
that they're under arrest
and we've told them
to go to Fremantle, Australia.
We saw this vessel
emerge out of the fog.
PETER: That would begin
what ultimately would become
the longest maritime pursuit
in history.
The chase stretched
across three oceans,
covering 11,000 nautical miles,
and covered 110 days.
(ship horn blowing)
MARIANA: And then
in the end what happened?
PETER: Ultimately, unable
to shake us as the pursuers,
the captain of the Thunder
decided to sink his own ship,
in an attempt to destroy
the evidence on board.
MARIANA: Were they able to?
PETER:
As they abandoned the ship,
three of my crew boarded
the vessel with cameras.
They were able to seize
nautical charts, mobile phones,
computer hard drives,
evidence that was
turned over to Interpol,
who then used that evidence
to chase down the owner.
She's going down.
MARIANA: Although several
crew members of the Thunder
were sent to prison,
the shipowner, like the owners
of the other Bandit 6 vessels,
remained free.
And Peter is confident that many
of those same players
are still active in
the illegal fishing game today.
WOMAN: At the moment,
they cannot see us.
They can probably see
a very small red light,
but not able to ID what we are.
PETER: And we've also
reduced the speed,
so we're matching their speed
of about three knots,
which is a speed
indicative of fishing.
So if they're just looking
at us on radar,
they're going to think
that we're another trawler.
MARIANA: Mmm.
So it's the perfect way to
approach a situation like this,
for a covert mission
like this one, I guess?
PETER: The perfect way
to surprise a fishing boat
is to pretend that you
are a fishing boat.
MARIANA: Hmm.
PETER: The plan tonight
is that we'll be assisting
the Liberian Coast Guard.
Kanbal III claims to be
a shrimp trawler
but may be doing something
very, very different.
MARIANA: In 2017,
the Kanbal III was approached
by another joint patrol,
conducted by Senegalese fishing
authorities and Greenpeace.
For more than 20 minutes,
Kanbal III's captain
ignored radio requests
to slow down
and to allow inspection.
(man shouting)
MARIANA: Once the Senegalese
authorities finally boarded,
they discovered
Kanbal III's nets
had been manipulated to create
a smaller mesh size,
thereby capturing more fish.
This is illegal
in most of the world.
They also discovered
that the crew
had attempted to undo
their net modifications
prior to inspection.
(man shouting)
MARIANA: How dangerous
are these operations?
WOMAN: What we are doing
carries some risks.
But we have the Liberian
Coast Guard with us.
We have a trained crew, and
that's what we are here for.
(radio chatter)
MARIANA: Being in a small boat
on the open ocean at night
is an unnerving experience.
It's cold,
you can't see a thing,
and you're surrounded on
all sides by deep, dark water.
♪ ♪
It's scary.
You feel small and helpless.
♪ ♪
As we get closer
to the Kanbal III,
I'm struck by the danger
of what we're about to do.
(man speaking foreign language)
MARIANA: Not only are we
attempting to board a ship
in the open ocean at night,
but we have no idea what
or who we'll find on board.
♪ ♪
(officer shouting)
MARIANA: I'm with the crew
of the Sea Shepherd
and the Liberian Coast Guard
as they board a fishing trawler
called the Kanbal III
that's been exhibiting
suspicious behavior.
♪ ♪
MARIANA: Pedro.
So, the captain
is actually Portuguese.
I just saw his passport
right here.
MARIANA: Certa.
MARIANA: Mm-hmm.
He seems uncomfortable
with my questions,
which makes me even more curious
about what might be found
on the boat.
MARIANA: Okay.
We go over the ship's documents,
and it looks like their license
allows them to trawl
for shrimp and crab.
But the Liberian Coast Guard
needs to see proof
that they're fishing
by the rules.
So they ask the captain
to reel in the nets.
Oh, wow. So you can see the fish
starting to come in.
They're opening up the nets?
Oh, wow.
♪ ♪
Okay, and this is essentially
what they have
the actual license
to be fishing right now,
is the shrimp.
I mean, I grew up
eating this, you know,
this is called lagostim
in Portugal.
I grew up eating
this kind of shrimp.
PETER: Here the shrimp
is maybe not even 1/10
of what the catch is, right?
And that's pretty typical
of a shrimp fishery,
this enormous amount of bycatch.
MARIANA:
Bycatch refers to the fish
or other marine species
that are caught unintentionally
while fishing
for a specific target.
In this case, shrimp.
To me, you know,
looking at some of these
and knowing that each
of these shrimp in Portugal
on a plate at a restaurant,
they can sell
for about 20 euros each,
and you can see the amount
of money that can be made,
not by these guys,
but by the big bosses, right?
The people that are actually
making the money from, you know,
thousands and thousands
and thousands of dollars
that we're seeing worth
of shrimp on this boat.
PETER: And here these guys
are making $150 a month.
This is not--like, the economics
of this does not trickle down.
MARIANA: It's an ugly reality,
but still no sign
of illegal activity.
So, I make my way
down to the cargo hold,
where the catch
is frozen and kept.
So, it says cangrejos, crab;
gamba, shrimp;
and, uh, captured in the
Atlantic, so very, very vague.
And then heading
towards Vigo, España,
and it says the importer...
yeah, which is a Spanish name.
Have you heard of this company?
WOMAN: Yeah, yeah.
We've heard of them before.
Based in Vigo, which is a city
in Galicia, a region of Spain.
PETER: You could tell
the captain was a bit evasive.
He didn't want to say that
the real ownership of the vessel
is in Spain.
There's Spanish language
documents on the bridge,
there's documentation
on the cartons of fish
that everything's
being exported to Spain.
To Vigo, Spain,
which is Galicia,
which is really the heart of
fishing in Spain, in particular.
MARIANA: And yet,
despite Peter's suspicions,
there's no evidence
of illegal activity.
PETER: Today the Liberian Coast
Guard has to let this ship go.
MARIANA: So the nets
of the Kanbal III
will soon be back in the water.
♪ ♪
I spent almost a week
on the Sea Shepherd
and learned one of the great
ironies of the fishing world--
that despite the fact that
almost 20% of our seafood
comes from the black market,
it's nearly impossible
to catch anyone red-handed.
But I'm not giving up.
I'm determined to find my way
inside this world
of illegal fishing.
PAUL WOODS: Yeah, this is
the global footprint of fishing,
mostly industrial fishing.
MARIANA: That's all the green
that I'm seeing right here,
all these little green squares?
PAUL: Yeah, each one of these
is an area where vessels
are fishing.
MARIANA: Uh-huh.
PAUL: There's 50,000
vessels out there.
MARIANA: 50,000?
PAUL: Doing, yeah.
MARIANA: Industrial, commercial?
PAUL: Yeah, just the big ones.
MARIANA: 50,000?
PAUL: Yeah, right.
50,000 vessels around the world.
MARIANA: Perhaps as much as 20%
of seafood brought into the U.S.
comes from the black market.
Yet, I'm still searching
for a way inside.
I'm hoping Paul Woods can
point me in the right direction.
He's the co-founder
of Global Fishing Watch,
a non-profit that uses
state-of-the-art data analysis
to monitor fishing vessels
around the world.
So if you are doing
illegal activities out at sea,
what are the chances you'll
actually be caught, in general?
PAUL: In well-regulated
countries,
there's a good chance
you'll get caught.
This is clear because
the U.S. is good at managing.
In Hawaii there's lots
of fish out here,
but they, uh, the, you know,
the U.S. Navy keeps them out.
Whereas, uh, in Africa,
in West Africa,
all the foreign fleets,
Spain and China, Korea, Japan,
and the United States,
you know,
they all just fish in there,
and they're not,
they don't keep them out,
because they're not good
at keeping them out.
We've had issues where
we've seen vessels on the map
doing something
we know is illegal,
we report it to the authorities,
and we tell them,
"This vessel is fishing
in your waters,
it's not on your registry list,
it's clearly illegal,"
and then we find out
that they were retroactively
granted a license to fish.
So this happens routinely.
MARIANA: Hmm. And why
do you think that is?
PAUL: Uh, well, because there's,
there's money to be made
in, uh, fishing
and, uh, licensing fishing.
You know, and that is,
you know, more powerful
than the need to keep
the fishery sustainable.
MARIANA: How frustrating
is it for you?
PAUL: Uh, it's,
it's pretty frustrating.
What you need is
for the fishers to know
that eventually, even if they're
not caught in the act,
they're going to, you know,
face consequences
for breaking the rules.
MARIANA: But right now,
that's not happening.
In fact, the criminals are using
the globalized nature of
the industry to their advantage.
PAUL: The vessel fishes
in one country,
it lands the catch
in another country,
it's flagged in a third country,
and it's owned by someone
in a fourth country,
and that's where
all the money goes.
So how can you even police it?
There's four countries involved
that all have to cooperate
in order to actually create
consequences for that owner
for their illegal actions
that happen on the water.
MARIANA: That's why
some shipowners take advantage
of what's called
"flags of convenience."
They register their vessel
in a foreign country
with limited oversight,
often as a way to skirt
regulations at home
or avoid detection abroad.
PAUL:
It's a global supply chain.
Everything gets mingled
and flows around.
So once, once it comes off
the boat and goes into that,
it's really hard to trace.
♪ ♪
MARIANA: The shrimp I saw
on the Kanbal III
is bound for Vigo, Spain,
home to the largest
fishing port in Europe.
Every year, more than
700,000 tons of catch
are offloaded here.
The fish are sorted,
sold and distributed
to countries around the globe,
including the U.S.
It's a massive operation.
High-tech, spotlessly clean,
rigorously controlled.
Every crate of fish is weighed,
catalogued, and barcoded,
so buyers know exactly
when and where it was caught.
(speaking Spanish)
MARIANA:
That's the theory, anyway.
In reality, any one of the
hundreds of species on sale here
could have been
transferred at sea
from an illegal fishing vessel
to a vessel carrying
the paperwork
to make its cargo
look legitimate.
(speaking Spanish)
MARIANA: Once the contraband
fish has been mixed
with a legal catch
in a ship's freezers,
it's impossible
to tell them apart.
It's one common way
that illegal seafood
gets laundered
into the legal supply chain.
But I haven't come
to Spain for the fish.
I've come for the fishermen.
The ones that have given Galicia
its rather notorious reputation.
PETER: Galicia has always been
a smuggling portal for Europe.
They've been involved in
trafficking not just of fish,
but of drugs and tobacco
and other illicit
products as well.
The companies behind vessels
involved in the poaching
of Patagonian
and Antarctic toothfish,
they're known
as the Galician Mafia.
MARIANA: I want to find someone
who's worked
on these illegal vessels
and knows the secrets
of this dirty trade firsthand.
After asking around a bit,
I meet a retired fisherman
who says he'll
give it to me straight.
♪ ♪
MARIANA: Perico is
a retired fisherman.
He says he spent 35 years
working on Spanish vessels
in the frigid North Atlantic.
Perico tells me
that his career at sea
was marked by constant
illegal activity.
MARIANA: Mm-hmm.
MARIANA: But when I press Perico
for the names of the worst
offenders, he clams up.
MARIANA: Mm-hmm.
MARIANA: And there's the rub.
Spanish fishing is,
at its heart, a family business.
A very big family business
that keeps its secrets close.
But then, a new lead.
Remember the Bandit 6?
One of which the Sea Shepherd
chased for 110 days
before the captain
purposely sank his boat?
Well, I was able to connect
with a local journalist
who has access to
a treasure trove of documents
relating to the investigation
of those vessels
and the ensuing court case.
If I want to find a source
deeper in this
illegal fishing world,
this could be my chance.
How does the fact that
we're talking about these,
you know, very wealthy companies
with fleets of boats
and fancy websites
and a lot of lawyers, how does
that complicate matters for you
in terms of being a journalist
and investigating this?
MAN: I have to be careful,
and, uh...
MARIANA: Can you tell me
a little bit
about what all these
documents are?
MAN: Those documents
are the outcome
of the, probably
the best investigation
on illegal fishing.
8,000 pages.
MARIANA: 8,000 pages?
MAN: 8,000 pages.
The investigation
was led by Interpol,
together with
the Spanish Guardia Civil,
on the Bandit 6.
MARIANA: I mean, they were
caught red-handed.
There's plenty of evidence
that they were,
what they were doing
was illegal, right?
MAN: Everything is proved here,
in all the documents,
that those Bandit 6
were committing crimes.
MARIANA: Incredibly,
the Spanish Supreme Court
overturned the case against
the shipowners of the Bandit 6.
They decided that,
while the Bandit 6
did commit illegal activity,
the courts did not have
jurisdiction,
because those
illegal acts occurred
in international waters.
MAN: Here, we have
all the coordinators
of the fishing activities
from Galicia.
MARIANA: Wow. So, these
are the names and contacts?
MAN: Yeah.
MARIANA: All the coordinators?
MAN: That's it. That's it.
MARIANA: Wow, this is great.
MAN: And in this all documents,
you have all the phone numbers
and some emails of those guys.
So you can try.
MARIANA: So they've all
actually been indicted, these?
MAN: Yeah. We have the name
of some offshore companies
used by those guys
of the Bandit 6.
MARIANA: There's evidence of
money laundering in this one.
MAN: Yeah, no doubt about it.
MARIANA: And here
you have the whole list
of the crewmen from this boat.
You have the captain,
the chief engineer, the cook,
and then all the officers.
There's phone numbers
for this one, too.
Passport numbers,
lots of photos, bank accounts.
There's just so much here.
You see that the chief engineer
and the officer and the captain
are all Spanish.
And there are Spanish numbers
associated with them.
This is big--
lists of names and numbers
of people directly involved
in the Bandit 6
and who might know what illegal
activities are still ongoing.
(phone ringing)
(beep beep beep)
MARIANA: Calling another person
that we know worked
one of the Bandit 6 boats.
(beep beep beep)
MARIANA: He hung up.
MARIANA: Okay.
MAN: No, no, no, no, no. No, no.
(ringing)
MARIANA:
Pick up, pick up, pick up.
MARIANA: Two and half hours now,
we've been making
call after call.
(ringing)
¿Hola?
MARIANA: So, today,
this afternoon, here in Vigo.
Great.
I finally secured
a face-to-face meeting
with a former crew member
from a Bandit 6 fishing boat.
He's texted me a location
on the outskirts of the city.
I think this is it.
Okay, here we are.
♪ ♪
I think it's here.
¿Hola?
♪ ♪
MARIANA:
The man I'm talking to--
we'll call him Luis--
spent time working on one
of the Bandit 6 boats,
as well as dozens
of other Spanish vessels
throughout his career.
He's my key to understanding
how illegal fishing works
at an international level.
MARIANA: Wow.
MARIANA: We have no knowledge
that any of the ships we boarded
had double bottoms
or illegal nets.
But it sounds like that was
standard operating procedure
on the Spanish ships
that Luis worked on.
And that wasn't the only way
they skirted regulations.
MARIANA: Mm-hmm.
Luis explains that within
the fishing industry,
it's the shipowners who have
the power to make change.
But those are the same folks
who are profiting the most
off the status quo.
MARIANA: He's right.
The real issue is not the need
for more regulations
or enforcement.
It's our relationship
to the oceans themselves.
I've been so focused on trying
to understand the black market--
boat owners exploiting
a disorganized
international system,
fishermen using altered nets,
captains turning off
AIS trackers--
that I've overlooked
the obvious.
A bigger, more devastating truth
about industrial fishing.
SYLVIA EARLE: The impact of
illegal fishing is enormous,
but it is relatively small
compared to the impact
of legal fishing.
MARIANA: Sylvia Earle
is an oceanographer
and the founder of Mission Blue,
a non-profit dedicated
to protecting our oceans.
She doesn't mince words
when it comes to her opinions
about the global
fishing industry.
SYLVIA: This is the biggest
wildlife trade on the planet.
We're waging war on the ocean.
And we're doing it
with a big smile on our face,
thinking, "This is great.
We have technologies now
that can go to places
we couldn't go before,
finding fish that were
not accessible before."
MARIANA: Her words echo
so much of what I've seen
over the last few months.
PETER: Shrimp is
maybe not even 1/10
of what the catch is, right?
And that's pretty typical
of a shrimp fishery,
this enormous amount of bycatch.
I, I always refer to bycatch
as the invisible victims
of industrial fishing.
MARIANA: The invisible victims
In other words,
a waste of animal life
like I've never seen before.
It's difficult to watch
and even harder to fathom
that it's all legal,
happening every day and night
on trawlers around the globe.
NEWS ANCHOR:
The stocks of tropical tuna
in the Indian Ocean
have been overfished.
NEWS ANCHOR: Human exploitation
of the world's oceans
is passing the point
of no return.
ANNOUNCER: Endless Shrimp.
It's as much as you like,
any way you like.
NEWS ANCHOR: A huge wealth
of creatures and habitats
are under threat,
decimated by overfishing.
ANNOUNCER: Our awesome,
mouthwatering snow crab dinner,
for only $9.99.
ANNOUNCER:
Have it all this summer
with the Crab Daddy Feast.
PAUL: Industrial and commercial
fishing is scaled up so much
that it really is a lot more
like mining than fishing.
These nets are enormous.
And they just take everything.
All the fish within a kilometer
out of the water all at once.
You're literally mining
the ocean of fish, of all life.
SYLVIA: We have the capacity
to deplete wildlife
on a scale
that is unprecedented.
Technology is available
to almost everyone everywhere
to find, capture, consume,
or market ocean wildlife
on a scale that is simply,
no matter how you want
to measure it,
it's not sustainable.
MARIANA: It's this future
that has me worried.
But even today, there are
plenty of warning signs
if you know where to look.
The experts I spoke with pointed
me to the coast of Ghana,
where a local fishing community
has been transformed
in ways I'm told
I won't believe.
♪ ♪
(beep)
(woman shouts)
♪ ♪
MARIANA: We got a call
late last night
saying to be at the port
at 5 a.m. this morning
because they had something
that they wanted to show us.
Um...
we're still not sure what
we'll be able to film or see,
but all we know is that
we're meeting this person
in about five minutes.
The call came from a local
fisherman turned crime boss
who's known simply
as the Chairman.
I was introduced to him
by a contact of mine,
but the Chairman has been
difficult to pin down.
I see a couple of boats
with lights here.
People working inside.
Let's check.
(unbuckles seatbelt)
(car door slams)
♪ ♪
Over here?
(man talking)
MARIANA: Is this it?
MARIANA: I guess this is it.
Yeah, come in?
Looks like that's
the Chairman on the phone.
His name is Justice.
MARIANA: Yeah, very fast.
We're very fast.
Okay, we have to go, guys!
♪ ♪
We pass by one fishing boat
that strangely doesn't have
any fishing gear.
They are clearly unhappy
about our cameras.
♪ ♪
This is one of the boats
that came out from sea today?
Can we stop there
and talk to them?
It's another fishing boat,
again with no fishing gear.
♪ ♪
MARIANA: Oh, wow.
Look at that.
It's all big blocks
of frozen fish.
So the whole boat is fill,
is all full of that?
CHAIRMAN: Yes.
MARIANA: These Ghanaians
used to fish for themselves,
but an influx
of foreign trawlers
has caused fish stocks
to plummet.
So, now, in a perverse twist
of their livelihood,
these fishermen go out to sea
and buy blocks of fish
that have been caught and frozen
by the trawlers themselves.
This came out from the sea?
CHAIRMAN: Yeah.
MARIANA: From the trawlers?
MARIANA: Yeah.
So they would throw it away,
and instead...
CHAIRMAN: Yeah.
MARIANA: ...the fishermen
go out and pick it.
CHAIRMAN: Yeah.
MARIANA: How far
are the Chinese vessels?
CHAIRMAN: 12 hours.
MARIANA: 12 hours to get there?
Through forces
beyond his control,
the Chairman has been dragged
into an illegal seafood trade
known as Saiko.
You have been working
as a fisherman
for a very long time.
MARIANA: You're originally
an artisanal fisher.
CHAIRMAN: Yeah, yeah.
MARIANA: And so,
since this is illegal,
why did you agree to talk to us?
CHAIRMAN: Well...
MARIANA: It's not.
MARIANA: Right, that it
helps a lot of people.
CHAIRMAN: Yeah.
MARIANA: So, what do you
say to people
who say what the trawlers
are doing
is that they are
destroying the oceans,
they're killing all this fish,
and you are
contributing to that
because you are buying
this bycatch?
MARIANA: Right.
MARIANA: The reality
is even more depressing.
What started out as foreign
trawlers selling their bycatch
has become so established
and so profitable
that many foreign ships
are now purposely targeting
local fish, which, of course,
has only made
the overfishing problem worse.
This is the trickle-down effect
of our global fishing industry--
a local population so powerless
to stop the overfishing
that it's now been forced
to embrace a black market.
(crowd murmur)
Oh, wow.
So, this is all the...
CHAIRMAN: Yes. Yeah.
This is the Saiko fish.
MARIANA: Another one there.
Make no mistake about what
you're looking at here.
This is a fishing town that now
survives on frozen fish.
I mean, it's incredible.
You look around, and all of it
is basically Saiko.
♪ ♪
You can see, it's just
boat after boat,
and all of them
are filled with fish,
and they're bringing
all the fish now to shore.
They cover it with blankets to
keep it cold, to keep it frozen.
Oh, wow! Look at that!
Holy (bleep).
That is insane!
So much.
So you can see
how big this boat is.
CHAIRMAN: Yeah, yeah.
MARIANA: And then every single
one of these, basically, holds,
is filled, filled, filled
with frozen fish.
CHAIRMAN: Yes.
MARIANA: Yeah, it's out.
It's open.
♪ ♪
PAUL: We can't do this forever.
There will come a point
where we don't have fish.
And the people that will suffer
are the people that go out
to fish every day
to feed their families.
But it won't be the owners
of the companies
that took all the fish.
They'll just go
do something else.
MARIANA: I'm almost embarrassed
to admit how blind I've been
to the ugly truth about
our global fishing industry.
But I can't unsee
what I've seen on this journey.
The industry needs to change.
We all do.
SYLVIA: Taking wild animals
from the ocean
and turning it into money
or products...
there's a cost.
There's a cost to everyone.
It's not free.
♪ ♪